[Applause]
no no yep okay I'd like to thank BAFTA
for inviting me to be part of the series
it's quite an honor so first off I'm
speaking with you tonight not as a
screenwriter but a screenwriter director
editor I've been all three on all of my
films and well to be clear a
co-screenwriter on five of my six films
I bring this up because my screenwriting
is actually very interconnected
with my directing and editing and so I'm
going to be speaking that way from
basically from the point of view of all
of all three of all three things so when
I write my films when I co-write my
films I feel as if I I write my films
three times the initial screenplay
written in a fairly conventional way the
only thing that may not be standard
about that initial screenplay is
slightly more screen direction on the
page and in sections in which I clearly
state that I'll be using a documentary
style approach to capturing a moment so
these are sometimes paragraphs or little
sections in the screenplay that give my
actors sample lines but I make it clear
that they'll be interacting with
pedestrians or non-professionals an
improvisation will be required for them
to you know for them
forgive me this is my first lecture so
ever ever so be patient be kind okay
okay so then there's a rewrite during
production and that happens basically
through my direction this plays out a
few different ways first off I always
encourage improvisation on set I find it
exciting and I usually work with actors
who who have that gift of improvisation
and I work with my actors in that
process so it's a it's it's basically
another aspect of writing it is writing
on set
if my actors are willing to discard the
written word and riff on the themes of
the scene it's my duty to guide them
through that and sometimes it's a dance
- back and forth where I hear something
I like but it might need tightening or
fleshing out so as a writer I take it I
I take what my actor gives me in that
moment and think of a different approach
and direct them on how to change it I
sometimes it's asking questions in the
moment sometimes it's simply feeding
them alternate lines that are thought of
in the moment as the camera is rolling
and it's really just it's almost having
a dialogue with my actors and it's a
back and forth so that's how dialogue
may be actually reworked and rewritten
but then there are the changes to plot
and character arcs and that we as my
filmmaking team we do our absolute best
to keep an open mind to that stuff
during production because I wanted to
organically live I want to tour again if
we grow so my initial screenplay is so
is more than a blueprint but I still
like to see it as a blueprint we usually
shoot just enough in chronological order
that we're able to see the film
from a bird's eye perspective and notice
if things need adjustment and my my co
screenwriter Chris Prakash it's very
important for him to be present on set
you know that's not usual that's not the
normal normal thing to do
usually a you know screenwriter well
you'll never see him or her on set but
it's important for me because we are
basically in the process of finding the
film the screenplay for a second time
there and I'm gonna give you an example
with tangerine my Chris actually was
present and realized that just by
observing and being on set that we
needed something more in our third act
and this was about two and a half to
three weeks into production
he came to me and he goes we're missing
we're missing something we have you know
our three act structure we have our you
know we have our reveals but there's a
third act twist that seems to be missing
and this simply came from him you know
analyzing what we had captured up to
that point and realizing that our final
scene would be more impactful if a
betrayal preceded it so close to that
third week of production we just took
the nights off you know that the nights
that we had and wrote a scene in which
it revealed that our lead character
Alexandra had slept with her best
friends man
and this change this this is a big
change because it requires us to then
rehearse with our actors to figure out a
night to shoot this it you know it's
it's it's a little bit difficult for
production to handle this especially on
limited budgets in time but in the case
of all well in font of five of my six
features significant adjustments like
that and additions have been made during
production so that's the rewriting
portion that takes place during
production and I just gave you a spoiler
as you you heard this is gonna be rifle
spoilers I'm sorry about that um so
spoiler alert from this point on okay so
then there's the third stage
post-production and this is where I
write the film for the third time
because I edit my own films I have the
Liberty to find the film all over again
in the Edit room and I really consider
this part of my writing very much part
of my directing you know it gives it a
signature it gives it at that moment I
get to to play with pacing I get to play
with I get to choose what I want in
there and what I don't I I approach it
like a documentary editor I guess you
could say and I also I also have had
wonderful producer
in finance years who have actually
allowed me to take a break after
production to take to get distance from
the footage so that and sometimes up to
several months you know mark and Jay
Duplass on tangerine actually gave me
over five months to remove myself before
going into the Edit room and this was
valuable this is this was invaluable
because it allowed me to when I come
when I came back to the footage it was
you know as I was seeing it with a with
fresh eyes and and then I tackle it as
if I'm editing a documentary and I get
to play I allow myself to play with the
chronology and and I this will only
happen if the continuity will allow for
it but the Florida project is a perfect
example of how I was able to reorder
seems quite extensively actually from
the way they were written and this is
for exposition pacing and emotional
impact I'm sorry I'm not how many people
in the room have seen the Florida
project okay cool enough so I can give
an example of that there is a scene that
now comes 25 minutes into the film it's
this this scene I called the Brazilian
tourist scene to Brazilian tourists on
their honeymoon show up at the Magic
Castle thinking it was going to be the
Magic Kingdom and they they're
complaining about the state didn't
they're in there trying to find they
were they obviously are not in the right
place
well this scene originally was written
on page 60 so essentially 60 minutes an
hour into the film what I found during
post-production was that the we needed
that exposition earlier we needed in in
many ways those tourists were our eyes
or you know Outsiders eyes in a way
representing the audience so giving that
giving the audience that information 25
minutes in seemed right it seemed
keeping the audience in the dark for any
longer I think what
would have would have would have
confused the audience too much so so
that's a big example of something taking
taking it from page 60 and bringing it
all the way back to page 25 now because
the film you know is a series of
vignettes to a certain degree continuity
was okay
you know kids are often wearing the same
thing you know it was a nighttime scene
that was separated so it didn't matter
if wardrobe changed and this is
something I do a lot but you know
Florida Project had a lot of this going
on so those that's an example of
basically those are the way that that's
my screenplay writing three three parts
and and I the only reason I bring that
all up is because that's that's a
disclaimer that you're basically the way
it's my way of saying that I don't think
I'm going to be able to speak to the
craft of screenwriting in the ways that
you might be used to hearing spoken
about you know I studied filmmaking at
NYU and as required I had filmmaking I'm
sorry a screenwriting course or two I'm
slightly familiar with the books of Syd
field and would William Goldman that
focus on the screenplay structure and of
course Joseph Campbell's hero's journey
however I try not to focus on the forms
of structure when writing I actually I
never want structure to be apparent you
know it's it's important for me it's it
it it the minute that I recognize
structure it takes me out I want to feel
like I'm living and breathing with the
characters and spending time with them
at least in my films you know and if
there's a three-act structure which
there are in my films I want the the axe
to be difficult to point out to find you
know for the act breaks to be blurred as
much as possible so when I was asked to
do this lecture this talk I thought I'd
speak about those screenplays that I
that I consider exceptional genius in
fact and and tell you why I think I
think this and I was going to choose
one screenplay and tell you all the
reasons I think it's wonderful and I was
entertaining Gary Oldman's nil by mouth
and was going to focus on the some of
the vignettes to make a powerful whole I
was thinking about Chang dong Ling
leaves oasis and was going to focus on
the humanist approach to telling a
sweeping love story of two social
outcasts I was thinking about speaking
of the clever use of the 1988 National
League Championship as a framework for
the for a story of corruption and
redemption in Zoe Lenz Bad Lieutenant
sadly the only screenplay ever produced
by this talent who left us too early but
quite honestly I began to realize that
it was actually it was the themes and
the sensibility of these scripts that
had more of an influence on my work than
the structure and plus as I just told
you I can't really speak to structure
that well and so I didn't really know
where to begin and a few nights ago
actually I was I was lying in bed and I
realized there actually is one film out
there that that really did have a direct
influence on my work structurally
speaking and and that that applies to
the last three films to be precise the
clips that you saw actually from starlet
tangerine and the Florida Project the
film is only 11 years old and it happens
to be a documentary and well you know is
there a screenplay for a documentary
well sometimes there's a script that's
that used as a way of guiding the edit
but it really depends on the filmmaker
and obviously documents or documentaries
are evolving there's now a hybrid of
documentary and narrative fiction
filmmaking that truly blurs the line and
in these films sometimes have
screenplays
you never know actually but the film I'm
speaking about is is essentially a
cinema verite documentary real events
that are captured on the fly into
cut with interviews of its subjects in
this case it is the Edit it's the choice
and the order of shots and sequences
that become the screenplay in my eyes
that's my take on it
the film is Jake Glen oles 2006 feature
documentary the great happiness space
tale of an Osaka loved thief this is a
very underappreciated film that I
discovered back in no7 and I fell in
love with it for many reasons it
actually happens to be a British film
and was nominated for a British
Independent Film Award for Best British
documentary the subject of the great
happiness space is Japan's host bar
scene where women pay for the company of
men and I actually have a clip to show
you so could we run coastal public to
people who talk about that
[Music]
[Applause]
wonderful man we did don't you probably
tell us how that's wrong misfortune
unless oh okay so I think he had a good
sense of the film in that clip it's set
in Osaka it's a documentary that invests
investigates the underground world of
high-end Japanese clubs attractive young
men service escorts for wealthy female
patrons and Jacqueline L followed the
male staff as they are taught how to
make themselves appear as objects of
desire the hosts can earn about 10,000
to 50,000 dollars a month and the owner
who is the the subject the the the the
focus of the documentary
his name is EC he's one he's the host of
the most popular club in Osaka and he
has a staff of 20 the young met the
young women who are patrons of the club
spend thousands a night for their
company bottle service
just just entry for the club it's very
expensive so when the audience learns of
the fantastic sums that the clients pay
for this privilege the question is
raised how can they afford to pay so
much and there is an incredible
fascinating reveal at 38 minutes in
which is for a film that runs 76 minutes
the exact halfway mark and I would like
to show you clip 2
you do it dear lady noodle on you or
something after their walk their Roman
goddess
[Music]
see what Allah
for
[Music]
no boy taka
yes to loosen up
co2 Ouattara yeah mother Karen this is
not their demo no more
so no he may have a lighter phenomena
yeah the university mankato
genome in Colorado no demo and in
high-tech artists quick on my dear demo
Vanga
it's Val where I type C egg away Cara
Moo death dr. Kunze Nanyang De Niro and
world agarrado all boca grande una
combat the Casa de Balliol
it's gonna kind of Allah
[Music]
he musta given in another day in America
when I tell them soon because Santa
Maria the war said nobody could support
us there at all don't notice tomato in a
zero at the wrong post on the wall all
night I know what authority the food's
open up whatever charitable Cara come on
yeah it's so as you can see most of the
clients at least the the high spending
ones are also sex workers and in that
flash the viewer realizes that the young
women who are searching for a kind of
love that exists only an illusion and
fantasy are basically providing the same
kind of love that they provide to their
clients does that make sense now let me
go back on that
what what's incredible here is that it
there's a mutual sustained illusion that
stems from the that very human need of
connection need for love and I see it as
a vicious cycle that is obvious of
obvious effects on everyone involved but
while the young men at the end of the
night may stagger home physically and
emotionally drained possibly because of
the guilt they suppress they've made
thousands of dollars while the young
women stagger home with nothing
including the love that they so
desperately need this this film had a
profound impact on me and yeah I
couldn't I could not stop thinking about
it for days it haunted me now if you
know my work you can probably see that
there are many reasons I find this film
so compelling the film focus is on those
on the fringe those leading alternative
lifestyles universal themes of love and
loneliness are explored as well as the
societal stigma of sex work and the
issues of exploitation
there are lots to there's lots of things
to explore lots of issues and topics to
explore in this film but it was that
twist that character reveal that made an
indelible impact on me as a screenwriter
and if if the information of the female
clients being prostitutes themselves was
given to the audience from the get-go
the film as a whole would not have a
fraction of the emotional impact it does
now now I'm sorry I had to spoil it that
way to you you know waiting 38 minutes
and under and thinking you know that
world and then getting that twist it
really it really is a punch to the gut
and I found that storytelling choice to
be very you know it extremely profound
and so what I want to talk about is this
sort of I I guess I can I guess I can
call it a character reveal and it's
something that I've tried to apply to my
last three films because of this film
and it's not what I think some some of
those who teach screenwriting call a
reversal of identity it's not that we're
you know the true identity of a
character is revealed so this isn't the
Norman Bates psycho thing or the you
know Darth Vader Luke I'm your father
moment but it's simply a reveal of the
characters circumstance and while this
might may not may be quite eye-opening
for the audience it's quite
matter-of-fact for the characters for a
you know for the subjects because our
characters have been living in this
circumstance for some time a reveal of
something significant in one of the main
characters lives which is conveniently
kept from the audience for approximately
half the picture to maximize the reveals
effect and this leaves the audience in a
place where they suddenly must question
everything they thought they knew about
the character reevaluate the characters
actions decisions and behavior up to
that up to this point and from that
point on also this reveal can challenge
the audience to re-examine the
characters place and role in society and
these are usually secrets but if not
secrets details about the characters
desires livelihood or history that they
don't openly share with the world and it
becomes in a way a privilege
for the audience to have these details
shared with them this reveal this
character reveal rarely changes the plot
or the course of the plot
however ideally it forces the audience
to question how and why they were
judging the character and how and why
their perception perception of the
character has now changed so I realized
that the some of the fiction narrative
films that have been the most emotional
impact and meaningful to my life and
career have a version of this this
device in their screenplays one example
Harold and Maude
Harold noticing mods concentration camp
tattoo this one shot reveals an integral
part of mods past it begins to make
sense at that point that mod would
celebrate life and freedom above all
else because those are the exact things
that the Nazis took from their victims
and when I was actually preparing this
and and it was then that I began to
fully realize the extent to which I've
been using this device because it was
very obvious for me I applied it to
starlet and I'll show you that clip in a
second
but I also see that it was in tangerine
and I also see that it's in the florida
project and again here comes the spoiler
so sorry but I'm going to show you some
some clips here first off let me show
you starlet now in this case we've been
with our protagonist Jane for over I
think 45 minutes so half the film and
there might be slight questions to her
about her livelihood hints that she may
have some sort of alternate career
alternative career that is and and then
this happens so can we play clip three
hey Jose
well yeah I'll be there at 10:00 okay
wait who am i working with tomorrow who
you talk to him for me and just kind of
like you know smooth things over
he just let things blow over for a
couple weeks we will be fine yeah
okay
walk in make sure he pees yeah have fun
today thank you
hi bye
do it girl they can tell me I want
because every time one of them mentions
me my followers go ugly really painless
can cover my third eye hi Tami how are
you good how are you okay make sure she
looks like million bucks tonight done
chin up cool
what like down a little bit and uh
remember the Stingers over there and
we'll good Tess how are you good this is
Manuel ok how are you very good to meet
you
alright guys grab a seat right there and
beautiful ok look good
much nice ok right cool we'll grab a
seat then we're just uh basically you
know Manuel trusting soul here it's
gonna take us FJ yeah the [ __ ] is this
man it's just a little dust you have to
full HD cameras right so this stuff is
gonna be home seat that's props props
that's what I didn't like to shoot here
this was your idea
no that's alright it's a great thing
somebody can guarantee a little ticker
this is very important I know it's done
right we're gonna take care of I want to
grab a seat way back there I'm working
so the scene goes on to be quite graphic
and I didn't want to show it here but
then I realized you showed quite a
graphic from tangerine a little earlier
so maybe I could have but nonetheless
this is uh you can see that I actually
you know took that device and applied it
to this revealing that Jane is a sex
worker herself in the porn industry and
challenging the audience to then think
about that and and why and how they are
they're judging her character
I then realized by by putting this
together that I did something similar
with tangerine and I don't think I was
completely aware of it until just
recently but it's it's a scene in which
I again it's a character reveal of the
Armenian cab driver
razmik and it well let me show you the
clip and then I'll to talk about so we
show the fourth clip
make a right right here on Las Palmas
look right here
no it's really busy on the streets today
so
are you from around here
now listen here before
you are beautiful
put a bun right here Oh the block is hot
over here there's a spot two blocks up
okay to the left right here so so nice
to see some fresh faces out here hmm
what's your name it's whatever you want
it to be yeah yeah what what can I help
you with it was usually have some exotic
names Selina yeah yeah
where are you from does it really matter
where I'm from you knew you mean time
I'm from Santa Clarita mm-hmm coming
through some French grace
get me real
that's wrong that's wrong is it tuns
[ __ ] your [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of my
Park [ __ ] out of my car all my time
that's not for [ __ ] all right you
shouldn't be there get on my carpet
[ __ ] homo me I much [ __ ] car
that's a white truck for you [ __ ] you
you don't work that try where's the door
close the door
all right so in this case obviously I'm
having a character reveal for a razmik
and this this scene actually was very
for me when the film was released in
theaters and I was watching audience's
reactions it's a very interesting thing
that happened this scene out of every
scene in the film got the most walkouts
and we were wondering why we were always
trying to figure out why it wasn't as
gratuitous or and it wasn't as I would
say is shocking any more shocking than
any of the other scenes but what has
what I believe happened is that this
reveal actually ended up to some
audiences out there some close minded
audience members I think it felt like a
betrayal to them I felt I think that I
think that perhaps some people who
needed the anchor of perhaps a cisgender
straight white male then all of a sudden
when we reveal razmik sexual preference
they felt as if they were betrayed by
the screenwriter and director and and
left the room left the auditorium so you
know that was a very it was almost a
psychological study it was almost like a
sociological study of the audience with
this scene and it wasn't something that
I was aware of until you know the film
was out there playing to audiences but
again it wasn't just until recently that
I realized that it's pretty much the
same thing this this scene comes around
40 minutes into the film after we've
spent time with razmik we we've we've
we've we've spent time on with his daily
routine picking up and dropping off
passengers and out of all the characters
I believe he would be the least likely
likely to suddenly throw the audience a
reveal like this or he would he would be
the audience would not be expecting
something from this character in those
terms so and then flipped the Florida
project I believe the Florida project I
also do this
at around the 50 at the around the
halfway mark it's it's it's it's I would
say a little more subtle but it is a
character reveal with with the Bobby
character played by Willem Dafoe and and
let's play it right now and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
happy birthday for you but I didn't come
on push but I didn't push then what you
do that why would you do that now you
call her and tell her I did hey first
jorts you get her on the phone and you
tell her Eddie Fisher anything damn
[Music]
appreciated the actual work no it takes
an hour and a half just to drive here
you totally screwed up my Saturday
that'll need the extra work give the
money to him he needs it or tell your
boss to hire an extra hand I can't do
this anymore
I'm done okay just
you should be starting
you get the principal but
so obviously a not seen through a lot of
mumbled words and very little dialogue
we we can get the sense that Bobby is
estranged from probably what probably
his Jack's mother his wife and and Bobby
is in a place where he is so isolated so
lonely that he is paying his own son for
his company and and and that's it that
doesn't it doesn't change the course of
the plot it's literally just giving you
a little more insight on who Bobby is
and perhaps you reevaluate and that's my
hope Yury evaluate his relationship with
the residents he has a reluctant
parental he is the reluctant parental
figure for many of the children there
and then you have to analyze what is it
in his own life in his own you know his
relationship with his son and with his
estranged wife that has and how that
affects his current relationships with
the residents so I hope that I have
given you a little bit of insight on one
of the devices that I find very
important in my screen place and
screenplays that I adore I hope this
wasn't too elementary for anybody out
there and I'm really happy I had the
opportunity to do this because number
one it allowed me to to spread the word
about a very underappreciated film the
great happiness space which I recommend
you all see but it also forced me to
examine my own craft it's something I
rarely do and I found this very
fulfilling it actually made me see that
common thread in the last three films so
thank you so much for this opportunity
and yeah Q&A time
[Applause]
so thank you so much for that sand we
took we don't take your disclaimer that
you can't talk about screenwriting
that's completely rubbish thank you
hello everybody um we've got and the
other thing is thank you so much as well
for introducing me to the great
happiness space which I you know knew
you were going to clip from today and
then I had a moment to kind of have a
quick look on YouTube yesterday and I
found myself going down a rabbit hole
it's a film it's impossible not to watch
and in fact I got to the point where you
showed the reveal there and yes instead
and yeah it's amazing I have to say get
on YouTube it's wonderful to see um Sean
there's so much to ask you about but
let's start with the kind of the the the
thing that's talked about so often about
you which is your ability to immerse
yourself in a world that's not yours
you are not black or trans or a
poverty-stricken young child or a
prostitute or any of those things yet
you can inhabit a world in a way that
most people cannot in with a really
incredibly authentic voice I wonder if
you've got any understanding of how you
do that I you know I really think it
just it comes down to being very aware
and unconscious of the fact that
representation is very important and
should be taken seriously and you have
to do it as a storyteller and as a
filmmaker it has to be done in a very
responsible and respectful way and and I
have been I've been fortunate enough
over the years to through my through the
pre-production stage you know the
research process to to when I when I
approached community saying I want to
make a film about this community or this
neighborhood or this subculture I found
people who want their stories told and
and and and for me I'm simply the
amplifier of the voice I'm not the voice
so when we when when Chris Berg and I
went into tangerine we literally went in
there knowing one thing or know two
things I'm sorry it was going to take
place on the corner of Santa Monica and
Highland and that there was going to be
a climactic confrontation in a Mike Lee
style at-at donut time and that was it
and that was really it because
didn't understand the world yet we
didn't we didn't if we hadn't spoken to
anybody where two cisgender white men
from outside of that world we needed to
find collaborators and and that came in
the form of Maya Taylor Maya was the one
who first showed enthusiasm who said she
wanted to act she had friends to
introduce us to she sat down with us
gave us her time so did her friends and
and then it was about asking them what
stories do you want told and and
basically after hearing enough where we
felt confident that we could then start
picking and choosing you know saying oh
that's it that's that's that's a great
little idea for maybe uh I've been yet
or there's here's a subplot or there's a
character yeah we can we can flesh that
out and it was one day that actually
Kiki was she indirectly brought us the
main plot of the film which was a search
for a cisgender woman who might be part
of a you know an affair with her
boyfriend and this was something that
didn't happen in real life but was
suspected for a moment so we rift on
that and we said how would this play out
in real life you know we we rat we ask a
lot of questions and I think that's the
big part of it it's it's it's it's
always asking for approval and and
asking for for people in the community
to sign off on it saying you know do you
approve of this is this the way it would
play that out is this this
representation
you know accurate and this has happened
for basically for every one of my films
to certain degrees you know it didn't
have to happen as much with Florida
because it's a film about childhood it
didn't have to happen as much with
starlet because again that's a
intergenerational relationship I can
pull from my own life on that but it
really stemmed from a little bit from
takeout in which you know we were living
above a Chinese restaurant at the time
and we we spent a lot of time in the
stairwell talking to the delivery men
before they went out on their runs and
then the following film prints a
Broadway which really was the one that
basically showed me how to do this
because prints abroad we took over a
year
that was a that was a tough one to crack
because you are you're dealing with the
wholesale district in New York City and
the men who are selling counterfeit
goods on the street are primarily
African undocumented African immigrants
so they don't want to talk to you you
know you you might be you might be ice
you might be NYPD or you might just be
annoying film students then they don't
have the time for and you have to and
it's about gaining trust it's about /
friending and and it's about again
hearing the voices of the community so I
hope that answers that question
absolutely except it's interesting that
you say you go back and check with that
community particularly old something
like tangerine that's that's interesting
to me because obviously that community
has lots of different voices there isn't
one way of being know so how so you must
have your own kind of your own
personality and has to come through and
you have to be the one to make the
ultimate decision about what a character
does that is true that is true but again
this is also a microcosm it is about
this area it's not about all trans
people it's not about all sex workers
it's not about all Armenian cab drivers
it's about this particular area and and
and and then you yes you do have to pick
one story you do have to go with one
story and and then it comes down to I
guess my own personal interests I really
do and what about your relationship with
Chris you started to talk a little bit
about it there um kind of how do you
check each other a kind of and
physically how does that relationship
work who goes away and does what I mean
you talked about him coming back with a
set but well we try to when we're
actually doing our journalistic approach
to do this we try to do our interviews
together you know Victoria Tate and I
actually she's and she's primarily an
actor but she helped me with the the
research process of prince of broadway
and she we were always together we were
always together asking the gentleman on
the streets to have coffee with us to
sit down with us so but with Chris it
really he also had taught with Florida
the Florida project because his mother
was living in
he also had a lot more access at at some
point then I did it wasn't until we got
like a grant that we actually started
taking trip that I started taking trips
there and understanding the world Morris
so it really depends it's project
project and then just expand a little
bit on the thing you start to talk about
about being an editor as well which is a
prison I'm sort of surprised that with
more kind of alter filmmakers there
isn't that kind of writer director edit
hybrid can you do you think it's a kind
of left-brain right-brain thing that you
you have one kind of attitude when you
start writing and then another when you
edit the only thing I can say about that
is there it is such a lengthy process
that you are in a different place when
you edit just your life has changed over
the course of a year and a half so you
might be thinking different things i
well let me ask with the project was the
last three films that you've done can
you think back to the original script or
perhaps kind of story colonel that you
had and then compare it to the kind of
thing that you ended up with at the end
of the edit and kind of how what's the
relationship between those two they're
sometimes drastically different and
sometimes not
tangerine drastically different in terms
of style we I told my producers going
into it there was gonna be no music no
no music
don't budget for music guys and they
they want to kill me yeah because it's
wall-to-wall music and it became that
way literally after the first day of me
sitting down with the Edit I well not
the first day I got past that opening
scene where the two women are speaking
in the in Dona time and then then Cindy
you know charges out of donut time and I
realized at that moment that well the
first off the film was shot in an
energetic manner and there's an energy I
think also in that neighborhood that
sort of was captured without me even
knowing until I started looking at all
this footage and I moved the camera more
I I had more coverage because maybe I
was shooting on the iPhones
more coverage and I and I had the
opportunity to cut faster if I wanted to
and this sort of story felt like it
needed that I take that back actually I
don't I don't think I had any more
coverage than in Florida but that I
think that tangerine needed that energy
that pulse a pulsating hyperactivity the
entire time well whereas Florida I want
I I truly wanted to sit and watch kids
perform it was very important for me not
to manipulate their performance I wanted
to show there was real child
performances so I slowed down the edit
there but with with tangerine yeah I I
had no idea was gonna be this
hyperactive I didn't know it was gonna
be this full of music until I was in the
Edit room okay and when you were writing
tangerine did you you talk about that
about making all-night phones which of
course is the kind of infamous thing
about the film did you know that's how
you were going to make it or did you
just write it no actually we we were we
are we had already written it okay and
that in part of the reason why we went
with the iPhone was initially a
budgetary reason we we had written the
film that basically could not be made
for the budget that we had and then it
was about where are we gonna cut costs
and the first thing I looked into was
the iPhone but then it's quickly within
you you quick when you do that with a
medium you you quickly have to look for
the aesthetic benefits of using that
medium because you don't want that
medium just to be dictated by budget you
have to then look at it as a way of
being able to capture something you
wouldn't with another media so so we
quickly realized that it was also a way
of blending in to shoot clandestinely to
shoot with first-timers and not
intimidate them so so so yes it came
after the initial scriptment was written
and when I see that's something I didn't
even bring up we have a script mint
before a total full screenplay which is
half a treatment habit a script script
that's what we call it a script
and it's usually what allows us to it
what gets us financing because as we are
I don't think our screenplay is ever
complete until just a few days before
shooting and then as I said during
shooting it's constantly evolving okay
and then having had that tons of
experience and going through to the
florida project which you presumably
knew you were not going to make in the
same kind of unconventional grabbed
style I mean how much did that change
the way you wrote do you think it
affected the kind of the choices you
made around scripting good question um I
I believe that no that was probably a
directing style that I only had in my
head to tell you the truth I knew I did
there is a line in the in the screenplay
that says there will be no score you
know that was I have some screamed
Direction some stylistic direction in
the screenplays even though Chris hates
that you know cuz you know Chris is very
influenced to stick right Chris oh right
just a writer right now yes okay I think
he wants to direct but um but right now
he is uh yes a full-time screen played
writer and he is screen writer and he he
he likes standard screenplay format and
and so when I do stuff like that it's
it's not considered professional but
it's necessary for me because I also
want people when they read the script -
I want the actors to understand that
when we'll be playing with them and when
you know when I'll be asking them to
improvise and I want my I want my DP to
understand you know my production
designer to understand things so I
really I do I I sometimes look at that
you know the traditional you know
screenplay format is as a little bit
limiting but anyway that's another topic
yeah okay this is interesting trajectory
you've got in you talk a little about
structure and I think that you're the
you know star
are relatively conventionally structured
and have a kind of fairly traditional
narrative albeit in a unusual world
Florida project is slightly less so I
think it's much more kind of a zigzag
and free-flowing
just kind of to talk a little bit about
about how you how you determined that
that was what you were gonna do this
time well I I always knew that with this
film I wanted to again as I've been
moving on up and trying to get away from
again recognizable you know standard or
recognizable techniques of the
screenwriting I wanted to as I said
earlier I have a three-act structure to
disguise it and cover it up as much as
possible if there is if it's John Rowe I
want that you know disguise or or hidden
but I but in this case I always wanted
to spend the summer with the children I
wanted to have the audience feel as if
they were just spending the summer with
the kids and getting to know the kids
personally so that the ending would have
the impact I'm hoping it has you know so
that we actually did it in our
screenplay we had scenes that were more
eye
I would say expositional we had scenes
that we and we shot those scenes but
they didn't make it into the final film
that's again why I'm saying I'm
rewriting I'm writing on in post as well
because I'm making that decision of how
much or how little were telling the
audience and there was a lot of
exposition not a lot but there was more
and there was the whole ending I would
say was the last act was way more
procedural like we actually told the
audience how an investigation like this
we were down we had scenes with the
caseworker talking to Haley and
explaining what she has to do and
getting into a lot of detail there but
every time as an editor every time I
started playing with those scenes were
trying to put them in it didn't feel
right and I knew in the back of my head
that I was shooting this I was scripting
and shooting this for safety sake only
if we really only if the audience was
truly lost and and every yeah we had
some we had some great scenes actually
there was a scene that took place in the
front in the lobby with mostly all
adults see that's the thing every time I
put in a scene which was primarily
adults and had didn't have any children
it felt like a different movie but
anyway the scene was a it was Bobby
Merrick who is the owner of the Magic
Castle the two clerks and they are
discussing the Yelp ads and and Bobby is
like no I'm Mary cos like what what does
the ratchet even mean you know and and
and he's he's thinking about actually
asking some of the residents to to write
some fake reviews for $10 each
in comes Bria or hailey and he says
young lady come over here ten dollars a
piece and Bobby's like no no don't go
there
not her and that scene was great and all
of the actors killed it but it just
didn't belong in the movie and so so
this is the first time that I've had I
guess the luxury of shooting stuff just
for safety purposes that's interesting
that you picked on that kind of social
work no element that you had to go into
a little more detail at you teased us a
little bit a certain tease me when in
your lecture by talking a little bit
about British realism and kind of
tradition of British realism you
mentioned know by mouth I know you've
talked a lot about Ken Loach before um
particularly in terms of something like
the social worker element I mean do you
see a parallel between the work that you
do and the work that somebody like Ken
Loach does I mean well I mean I look to
him as just in that a master and his
entire career is just incredibly
aspirational and inspirational and I um
I don't think I could ever even consider
myself like I wouldn't even want to make
this parallel school I wouldn't feel
worthy but at the same time I do feel
like we
perhaps our well we're tackling similar
subject matter and and perhaps you know
my style is is it's a little different a
little
poppier it's a little you know I know
sort of the audience that I'm trying to
get and I I feel that I'm using I'm
trying to let's just say with the
American audiences right now I feel as
if you tell them that they're going to
get a politically heavy handed film you
won't get them in the theatres and this
is a sad thing this is something that is
unfortunate but it's also something in
which then as a filmmaker I've had to
figure out ways of just I think
tangerine really opened our eyes to this
because we we tackled it in a way where
you know humor was first and foremost
and and so people call it a comedy and
it is supposed to be entertaining it's
supposed to entertain an audience for a
certain amount of time but then
hopefully leave them thinking about you
know issues or thinking rethinking the
way that they look at certain groups etc
etc but I feel that that was definitely
one tangerine did that for us and we
realized that was the first film to
reach a greater audience and it may have
been because of the style we we applied
this to to to Florida using the humor of
watching little children as and just
focusing on the joy of children and and
using that as a way of hopefully pulling
audiences in what's interesting you say
that because I thinking about the kind
of Ken Loach connection which I know
you've talked about a lot I actually
thought there was lots more parallels
between you and the kind of new
generation of you know our replacement
for Ken Loach and people like Andrea
Arnold and Clio Bernard or Lynn Ramsay
and actually one of the things that they
all three of those do I think I'm just
making this up as I go along but I think
they all have a kind of fascination with
kind of children in peril there's a lot
of children in parallel in movies and
actually you know a lot of what you did
there's a lot of tension particularly at
the outset there's a lot of tension
you're not sure where you know how much
peril you're going to put your children
in right yes yeah I see that connection
as well I I do have to say though that
also I I think I was very influenced by
earlier Ken Loach especially Cass and
riffraff if you think about remember the
soccer scene and castes of course that
is incredible
and it's one of the funniest scenes ever
captured on film
it's laugh-out-loud funny and so is a
lot of those scenes in riffraff I don't
think people remember the interaction
between those men and just the
behavioral comedy and so you know I
actually do feel that you know using
using him as a model of you know tak
going you know political subjects doing
social criticism but then at the same
time always having those human moments
that make you smile and make you laugh
and make you realize the okay you are
watching real people that you can
identify with and connect with that's
something that I believe really stemmed
from him so not kids in peril then let's
have a quick look at some of your kids
making his laugh okay
[Music]
don't you think we're going too far do
we have enough
[Music]
because we don't have any money we as
have five cents yeah we just have mine
and the doctor said we have asked one we
gotta eat ice cream right away yeah my
gosh guys we're not lying it's fine talk
about you know making didn't do kind of
scenes like those and how much to what
extent they were improvised to what
extent they were your words let's see
that scene um don't be a loser okay
what does it she says she says okay but
don't call me a loser whatever that was
improvised that moment the this the
scene where they're I mean the shot were
there outside talking about or asking
for money I gave them sample lines I
gave them a bunch of lines to say so
Christopher asking for ice cream because
he has his doctor says he has asthma
that was actually I think workshopped
I think that was one of those works
because we did a lot of rehearsals with
the kids and we had asked them sometimes
to put it into their own words and that
was something that he did in a rehearsal
that we really loved and just said do
that again when we're on set the rest is
pretty much scripted and some of it was
scripted and post like the walking past
orange world that dialogue was actually
ADR and we had Brooklyn and Christopher
performance okay and with somebody like
Brooklyn who I seen on stage I'm sure
some people have seen the you know I've
seen her interacting with the press
interacting with the public
I mean she's clearly a livewire yes how
do you rein
but he like that aim without [ __ ] so
meaning no but she's a livewire but
she's a professional life where it's
like she she she you don't have to rein
her in the only one time when I felt
like it was a mistake to ask the kids to
improvise was when they were doing her
tour in which we should we showed that
earlier right where they're giving the
tour of the Magic Castle I thought that
I would just be able to to feed them
lines from behind the camera and follow
them up and down you know the walkway
and have them riff well no it's when all
three kids together it starts to go off
the rails and especially because
Christopher that day was was obsessed
with Deadpool it had just come out in
theatres so all we could say was
Deadpool lives in here Deadpool is
saying no Deadpool doesn't live at the
Magic Castle this let's move on so after
we actually had to go back and shoot
that a second day and this time have
what more scripted lines for them and
and so yeah that's the only time where I
felt it did get out of hand in turn yeah
but um for the most part you know
Brooklyn is just incredible and
especially when she's alone working with
the adults it's really just it's if
she's on the same level as the adults I
mean she's she's uh she'll know when and
when not to give you know she she or she
has proper instincts I mean really
incredible instincts as an actor -
what's funny and what isn't it's really
it and she pulls a lot from I think her
own life I think you know that scene in
which she's eating at the end and we're
just sort of observing her or
documenting her eat to a certain degree
this is the scene where they're there at
the near the very end they go to the
higher end restaurant to the brunch and
we just are watching almost the the
mother's POV as we're just watching her
eat and we gave her a number of scripted
lines and she got through those scripted
lines pretty quickly and then we had
about another nine minutes on the
magazine just to watch and so that's a
that's what I described earlier there's
a
and forth I'm behind the camera so is
Chris so is Samantha Quan who are acting
coach and we're just basically feeding
her lines and asking your questions I
hey what would happen if you put that
strawberry in that raspberry in your
mouth at the same time and then she
would do that and and and she would tell
us what what it would taste like and she
was so wonderful because as a comedic
him somebody who is wonderful comedic
improvisation they never give you what
you suspect or what you expect I'm sorry
so she would say putting a strawberry in
a raspberry in your mouth you would
think that would taste pretty good
actually but she goes man oh man that's
gross you know and that's a perfect she
and I'm sure she didn't find it gross
see because she loves food and but she
knew it would be funny if she said man
oh man that's gross so that's what how
smart she is she's really a prodigy and
then I would feed her lines and then she
would take it to the next level so I
would say tell tell tell your mom that
you wish you had a bigger stomach so you
could eat more food and she goes I wish
I had a bigger stomach like I was
pregnant
but and then she acted and she that was
her and so she elevated it she brought
it to the next level and then we're
trying to analyze it later that night
Samantha and I were just thinking what
got her to say that and then we realized
oh well her mother was pregnant at the
time that we were shooting so it's like
you can see it's coming from a child's
head of what they're absorbing it and
with her and what she's spitting it out
to us it's pretty incredible um we're
gonna take some questions in one second
just what we do I just you talked I
thought it's fascinating what you said
about the reveal and kind of how
explicit you are and how much you leave
to the sides um with um with there's a
really key scene about at the point when
you realize that Haley is is a process
prostituting herself again
and you are not explicit about it you
just we just see Mooney in the bath you
know you you let us kind of figure it
all out I think that means that you
really trust your audience is that oh of
course
yeah yeah you have to you can't play for
the lowest common denominator because if
you do what sort of film are you making
you know you have to hope the audience
is on your level or higher but as you
become more you know the budgets get
bigger and you there are more people
involved in your process
have you had to do you have to fight to
kind of keep that no so far no so far
I've worked with wonderful producers and
Finance ears who have no problem with
that of course there's always questions
there's always notes you know like when
we did we have you know the repetition
of the three tub scenes before the
fourth one that reveals what's going on
and yeah there was a question I got a
note are you sure this isn't too much
are you sure we're keeping the audience
we're we're not keeping the audience and
it - in the dark too much that they'll
be turned off or or upset and and I was
like no I'm I don't think that I think
I'm moving on and they were they were
great with that you know that I'm
working with a team of people who who
trust me so yes let's take some
questions I think we have some mics on
either side so if you could as one down
here and then one here next first many
things I think that was a great talk
opening the door to your set and in a
way and you know just water if we can
crack it a little bit a little bit more
you're talking about working with non
actors as well as as well as actors and
you also have these coaches and advisors
around I just wonder how that works how
do you manage all the levels of
expression and confidence and so on if
you can talk a little bit more about
that sure
well I've been you you have to take the
time to cast right you know you have to
you know I've been the first timers that
I've
on have all had confidence they've all
had skill they've just never acted
before
and so Brio was probably the most
extreme case of never having at 100%
green you know Maya Taylor and katana
Kiki Rodriguez at least they would
perform on stage at least they did know
they they were Kiki even had some within
a high school drama group so as Prince I
do so I think of all the people I've
worked with in terms of first-timers
Bria was the one who's the most green
and but it was about but she also showed
that she had the motivation to to to
learn and and and would put in the time
you know she came she didn't have to but
she came a month early from shoot she
came a month earlier from a shooting and
before we needed her to basically spend
time with Samantha and myself and and
gets her to a place where she was able
to hold her own with Willems so it was
um but how it's it's a unset it's really
it's all about different personalities
you have to treat everybody slightly
different you know with Willem I don't I
heard they have to say anything and you
know he's a skilled transformative actor
with years and years of experience so
our talks primarily happened in
pre-production when we were talking
about the character and I knew he was
already there by the time we were
shooting so if anything there were minor
tweaks oh I'm not sure I really love the
way that you deliver that line can we
try something else I would never give
him a line read by the way but with
first-timers it's okay to give a line
read a line read can sometimes very
insulting to a seasoned actor so so with
Willem you know it was it was it was
actually he made my life easy
he made my days easy with him but then
with the the the other actors you know
it's all based on their level of
experience and and and their
personalities and what they how much
they need how much they need handhold
again I really don't think I would have
been able to make this film this way
without my acting coach with the kids I
mean they really spent a lot of time
with them every single day when I was
off shooting some scenes with the adults
or a location scouting they were always
in those motel rooms with doing
exercises games to get them to that
place so that when I was shooting with
them they could I could ask them to you
know to to loosen it up if I needed it I
hope that answer that question okay hi
hi Sean thanks for your talk um you
talked about the three phases of
screenwriting
and I'm interested in what happens
before the first phase in terms of
before you decide on a concepts how do
you prioritize your ideas and you know
kind of get them to that place of
actually wanting to start oh oh that's a
good question I think I'm in that right
now
it's it's there's so many factors that
go into that
you know usually it's the it's it's
whatever film you've just made that
helps dictate but the next one is in
terms of audience response and and in
terms of the impact it's had or or the
subject matter you've covered whether
you want to cover it again or in a
different way and so it really for me
you know I've been the the initial
stages or the initial stage is really
just a lot of brainstorming and a lot of
getting on the phone with my my co
screenwriter and and discussing the
possibilities and then also figuring out
each film has you know you're also
dealing with them you're hoping to
increase your budget so that sometimes
will dictate things but we do we do get
to it a treatment as soon as possible
that's very important and and the
treatment has the ending that's very
important for me I always have to at
least understand how this film will end
and I think for all of my films we've
known the ending from almost the onset
yes now not specifically meaning the way
it played out it's slightly different
than what our original concept was that
she ran to the park alone that was five
years ago then as we started to get
closer we thought it was actually gonna
be Moony that took chancy to the park
and then as we just closed to production
when we realized that we were that it
was all the whole movie usually what
happens is I figure out what the movie
is in production and and it was very
close to production and I figured out oh
okay
Mooney has basically shown Jancy the
world
she's been her tour guide the entire
time now Mooney is in of in the worst
place in the most vulnerable place she
doesn't have control anymore
so it's time to give control to Jancy
and to let her guide her into whatever
that last moment is however you want to
interpret that but so that was we did
but we did know it was gonna be an
escape to the park from almost day one
thank you for taking us through how you
write your script before you need
directing and then editing and then at
the end when the film finishes then I
think they scrape finish I just want to
know your views when you look in other
people's filled with films when the
scriptwriter different than the director
than the editor
do you consider some of those films the
editor and the director actually writing
the script like what's the last part of
the question yeah
when you're looking at other filmmakers
film was certain films that because you
separated these elements certain
directors even they haven't written the
script or the editor hasn't got anything
to do with the script actually those
personnel actually actually they were
writing the script at the same time they
were doing their jobs well I think I get
what you mean I
this only applies to my thumbs it's
really my that's why I said I'm a I
consider myself a director writer editor
it's all one it's how I make my movies
when I go to see other people's films to
tell you the truth I try to go as just
an audience member just just escaping
into that content like everybody else
and and and and what and how it works
you know I don't I don't try to take
apart whether I can see three different
heads I don't or two different heads
that's not important to me you know I'm
always just judging a film one as a
whole so yeah I do
directed somebody else's script I I
would love to I mean I actually and I
mentioned Zooey lund earlier and I
actually looked in to see if she had any
other unpublished or unproduced
screenplays and unfortunately I don't
think she does but but yes of course I
mean yes I would
there are incredible screenwriters out
there and I just and it's about but I
often will talk after one down here and
then one here running quickly out of
time Jagannath
just speak um thank you very much it's a
brilliant film folder project and a
brilliant thought just now and I found
it really interesting that you were
talking about the end of the film and
you knew it because that was what my
question was gonna be about was the end
of the film because I felt like a foyer
the whole time like I was watching their
lives and at the end it turns into a
fantasy they're running off to the park
and I thought it's interesting you said
they pacifically that you the end about
going to the park and I wondered if you
could tell us a bit more about that
process of turning it into that fantasy
why you wanted that to be the ending
there why the park kind of comes in the
location it's in Florida you know it's
this is it all comes at that very end
and it the pace the film speeds up it's
been quite slow and it's only really
speeds up at the end and I wonder if you
could tell us a little bit more and
especially since you knew that from the
very beginning right yeah I and I hope
you don't mind I'm not gonna go into too
much detail because the whole reason I
really did want to allow the audience to
interpret it I I know that even it was
it was even my co-screenwriter has a
slightly different interpretation than I
do so it's something that I think allows
itself it it allows itself to be
interpreted in different ways
I do say though its we are changing
mediums that is at a very vital moment
when when little Chauncey grabs Muniz
wrist and so I am telling the audience
that perhaps we are no longer in reality
and and I also I'm hoping that audiences
see you know they've spent the entire
film watching Mooney use her sense of
imagination and wonderment to to make
the best of what she has and perhaps
this is the audience in in the mindset
of a a child using that imagination to
make a happy ending because it yes
thoughts of them well that's it that's a
scene I'm glad you brought that up
actually because that is why I love
working with my co screenwriter Chris
Prakash because as I got closer to the
ending as an edit in the Edit I was I
was I was concerned about the end I
didn't you know again in my script I
said no score we only knew we were gonna
have a celebration play in the opening
credits and the rest of it was supposed
to be devoid of music except for what
came out of a Lee's radio and as I was
getting closer and closer
I was really realizing it's not gonna
have the impact that I needed it to have
I got on the phone with Chris and he
said why don't you do an orchestrated
version of celebration it's simple oh oh
yeah okay cool man thanks that's how
that that happened but again that's why
collaboration is so important and when
you're writing and when I'm working with
co-screenwriter it's not just about that
initial stage it's about all the way
through to the very end
nice to meet you I've already watched
the frog way that project five times
since can film or festival and I really
love this film actually so I have a
question about the film and for you love
with the ending I mean I love the ending
so is this your initial plan to have an
open and open ending or when you add it
it's film and there's the idea come up
with your man okay I have to put this
film with the open ending and as a
screenwriter how to make an ending to
become attractive and impressive to the
audience thank you well well I I guess I
kind of answered the first part right I
knew it was going to be that ending from
the very beginning I didn't know it was
going to be as polarizing as it is
actually on Twitter it's quite
but I also didn't care about that you
know I then it was about you know in
allowing the audience to interpret it
and if they didn't want to interpret it
well that's that's their fault that's
their problem
so but I I liked open-ended endings the
reason why is because it gives something
for the audience to talk about on the
way to their car during the movie it
gives them something if you wrap it all
up perfectly you know they give the
audience nothing to think about and
nothing to ponder I there's there's
another way I could have ended this film
I could have had her crying in the
backseat of the police vehicle and would
that have been a satisfying ending i I
don't personally think so but I know
that some people would rather see
something tied up in a law-and-order si
si bow you know so I I like endings that
leave me thinking and and what was the
second part well that I don't know I
mean I'm just I'm just making again it's
when I get to that stage of the edit
it's really just about or that that
stage it's um it's just about making the
ending I want to see and and hoping that
it has the same impact on audiences as
it would play with me we're not going to
ask because we probably cut short of
time but it means you know if you're
five different experiences of seeing
this film gave you five different
interpretations of the ending not really
good one hang on one second
thank you I was wondering if you could
tell us a little bit about production
and shooting the florida project as most
of us have seen it here tonight how long
did it take did you take over an actual
motel and that wonderful ending we've
all talked about were you at Disneyland
or was that green screened how did you
get that shot okay well lots to talk
about but basically really quick 35 days
of product
I needed a lot more I asked for 60 I got
35 when you're dealing with kids you
really just want a lot you know you want
too many days and now again I was very
lucky that these kids were so wonderful
that we were always getting our takes
within you know we were we were getting
the scene within I would say or shots
that is we were getting the shots within
two or three takes we did not take over
the motel entirely we we actually just
rented out rooms and told them that we
would never interfere with their
business or or their customers and they
this is something I've been doing with
all of my films I don't want to ever
truly own a running business because I
want I want the energy that comes from
and I want I want that that that feeling
that that life is going on and you get
that you being there on the set you know
you can ask people or the real clerk's
to participate the real residents to
participate I love that stuff and and
let's see what else we what are some of
the other questions that the other oh
the ending that was shot on Disney
property with an iPhone with an iPhone
that was really that's really all I want
to say but ya know it was it was a
overall you know I think everybody
always says that you know any filmmaker
says it was a difficult shoot I almost
never heard of a filmmaker saying oh
that was a breeze you know it's always
it's always difficult it's always
painful to a certain degree and and this
one was no exception and you know is a
there were lots of things it was me also
learning how to I've worked with larger
crews I've worked with Union crews on
television but never on my own personal
presenter my features very personal
passion projects and so I to work with a
larger crew you know they're a lot more
communication has to happen and I had to
learn how to
indicate with people who've never worked
with me before so they didn't understand
my style and I had to I was throwing so
many curveballs I mean at you know we
will go off schedule and that will
affect every single department you know
every single department has to say wait
a minute I was all prepped to do this
scene now I'm doing this scene and so
there was a little bit of at first there
was some fear but what happened quickly
is that everybody sort of got on board
and I had a lot of wonderful champions
on the film for example my my my
cinematographer alexis sabe he's used to
shooting like this I mean he shot two
features for Carlos a goddess I'm sure
they're not conventional and so he
basically just just and he is that is a
wonderful attitude in a way of speaking
that he was just like guys we're doing
something different here what's the big
deal you know okay it's gonna be
curveballs but where it's gonna be
different
it's not gonna be cookie cutter and
that's what that's what matters in the
end and so eventually I think everybody
was on the same page it was hairy at
first but everybody got on the same page
and and ultimately we knew we were
leaving we had to get everything we
could never go back for pickups and you
know the main reason we couldn't go back
for pickups cuz the kids were growing
right in front of our eyes so even one
month later it seemed like we are
looking at we were facetiming with
Brooklyn and saying we could never shoot
you right now you already looked
different so knowing that everything was
gonna happen have to happen in those 35
days and we're gonna have to just leave
with what we got that was a way of just
saying you know this is this is our one
chance let's that's pulled together
that's to be positive and let's just
make something we're all proud of sure
we have to let you go but just before we
do you talk about the kind of need to
decompress between films to come and
take a soak up the world around you I
think you said kind of in the pores
between believe me you're doing that now
you have any sense of where you gonna
hit next no no no I there are a few
ideas and there were a few they're not
even scripts they were just if anything
treatments one page treatments that are
sitting on the backburner and so we're
we're in sir
painting those but we're hope to be
getting another grant from sinner each
to allow us to start exploring and but I
think this is this also this film I
really do want it to have an impact in
the states you know I'm meaning that I
there has to be and and how this is
gonna play out I'm still unsure because
we're exploring options but we do want a
social outreach campaign that helps you
know that not only brings awareness to
the issue of the hidden homeless but it
also directly helps the agencies that we
worked with because they were so giving
to us and we want to make sure that they
are given something back and so far the
film has been helping them but on a
small level we want this agency in
particular that we even shot the
caseworker seen at the community Hope
Center which is basically kasym YZ and
Osceola counties Housing Authority
that's see that they don't have the
infrastructure there to actually have
their own Housing Authority and the
government so they outsource it to a
faith-based nonprofit and and they are
trying their best to to to develop a
complex of affordable housing on their
property and we're trying to our best to
try to figure out how this movie can
help make that happen for them well this
is a perfect place to leave it
thank you so much but
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]